[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
Loras I prefer to think of it Dear John
and Hank it's a podcast where my brother
and I we answer your questions did you
do B this advice and bring you all the
week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon and this week's dear Hank and
John is a little bit different how is he
different John well we are actually
sitting across from each other in my
office here in Indianapolis because you
have been kind enough to fly here just
so we can do some IRL podcasting I - I
face-to-face yes head-to-head yes how do
we prove to them that we're actually
sitting here together hmm we could make
a high five high five did you hear that
it was legit what about this one oh
you're right it's so easy to fake yeah I
was just clapping that I think people
will just be able to tell because the
vibe is gonna be different yeah yeah
we'll be more frustrated with each other
and more angry and more I think
despondent Hank that reminds me of what
a funny podcast this comedy podcast is
Hank would you like a short poem for
today I doesn't matter because you're
gonna get one uh this is a very short
poem to make up for the longest short
poem I read a couple weeks ago this is
called you fit in to me by Margaret
Atwood are you familiar with this poem
no no it's a good one you ready you fit
into me like a hook into an eye a
fishhook an open eye that was a short
poem very short I like Margaret Atwood
that's my kind of poem yeah well that's
Margaret Atwood your kind your kind of
writer for sure she's great and I I've
always liked that poem because there's
so much you complete me and you fit in
to me and we compliment each other
poetry out there that she sets your
expectations up pretty carefully and
you're just picturing this yeah you know
this this needle and this thread and
then and then you're not yep all right
how are you Hank what's going on what's
new well I just flew to Indianapolis
yeah so boy are my arms tired
oh god
cancel the podcast yeah which it's a
lovely place yeah I will say that you
are office is a place where I will never
let my employees go because how poorly I
treat them in our not very nice office
that's very nice here and and your house
is lovely your family's lovely and your
tone is lovely it is Indianapolis the
airport is amazing we have an amazing
airport and do you have good cookies
I've heard but I'm able to try them are
you something looking forward to these
great cookies yeah parents are here and
my wife is here it's just a family it's
good family time
yeah enjoyable no it's beautiful and
we're very happy to have you here thanks
for coming we've been here because it's
the annual meeting or semi annual
meeting for dftba.com the the web store
where you can find merch I don't have
any dear Hank and John merch we don't
have dear Hank and John merch what did
what a disaster for this particular
moment where we're talking about it
would be great to have something to
advertise however you can go and buy
Hank and John's stuff from phone cases
to jewelry to t-shirts to posters check
it out at dftba.com today's podcast
actually sponsored by dftba.com so you
want to answer some questions I think
that's probably a good idea since it's
what we do can I ask the first one sure
Dear John and Hank this question is from
Brooke she writes I am a freshman
starting high school this year I'm also
starting in a completely new school what
are some ways to make new friends
I feel like this question was designed
for me Hank because as you know I have
made one friend in the last 12 years of
my friend Chris waters my best friend if
a person who you made friends with
completely outside of the environment of
school yes but so I made the one I made
one friend yeah that's the first time
I've made a friend
since school so I'm pretty proud of
myself and then I'm also very good
friends with his wife Marina waters but
I met her through him right in fact all
of my other friends are either people I
work with or people I met through
so my first recommendation would be
Brooke to make friends with Chris I mean
he's amazing
you introduce you to done the pimple no
no no none of your fellow freshmen in
high school
they'll all be adults so that would
probably be weird let's uh let's try to
find some better advice than that
because I don't think that's good high
voice it's hard it is hard and in my
experience it is it is also I know it
was never something that I did
intentionally until I was an adult it
was all something that just sort of
happened to me and I think that that's
okay
but I definitely found myself hanging
out for a long time with people I didn't
really dig that much and then I would
find like one person who would actually
get along with and then latch on to them
and spend all my time with them which is
fine mm-hmm
and that's you know you're the
quintessential best friend and then and
then finally it took me you know and -
until like senior year of high school
until I had like a group of friends who
I who I felt like I would have been
friends with them even if I hadn't just
been thrown into a situation with them
that sort of like created the friendship
right I mean there's a lot of like
friendships of convenience not just in
high school or college but also in
adulthood but you know my my main
recommendation is to try to be nice yeah
there's a great line in the movie Harvey
in this world Elwood you must be oh so
smart or oh so pleasant for years I was
smart I recommend Pleasant I it's it can
be very hard to be nice especially when
people are mean to you
but I believe that if you are if you you
know if you try to be a good friend if
you try to be a good listener if you try
to ask questions and be become genuinely
interested in the lives of people around
you some of them not all of them
unfortunately but some of them will in
turn you know treat you the way that you
are treating them and
I believe that good friendships can come
out of that but it is not easy and I
think the main thing that I would say is
that like it's also you also have to
remember that like it's not easy for
anybody else either even the people who
maybe seem like they're popular seem
like they're comfortable or confident
probably aren't nearly as comfortable
and confident as they as they as they
appear to be but it isn't easy and I
think that you should you know it's okay
to be scared but but also bear in mind
that like it will get easier it will get
better like in the same way as you know
your first day doing anything is not as
easy as your hundredth day you know once
you're settled in that new school and
things will get things will get easier
but I wish you well and certainly
listeners of dear Hank and John if you
happen across Brooke at your school be
nice to her she seems like a very sweet
person we have another question this one
is from Chris who asks dear Hank and
John I understand respect to your
passion for the planet Mars I've got to
stop you right there Hank I am not at
all passionate about the planet Mars
Chris this question is for Hank he said
that that this question is for Hank it's
for Hank just for Hank yeah but I just I
feel like I'm being excluded from the
podcast so I just want to establish
right now that I have no passion for
Mars there are very few cold dead rocks
I care less about as our closest
neighbor in space chris says it is hard
not to be fascinated by Mars unless you
are John Green however I wonder if it
isn't becoming just slightly passe to
care so much about the inner planets
with the huge amounts of data streaming
from New Horizons Cassini and other
explorers in the outer solar system
would you consider focusing some of your
attention on that great beyond
capitalized by the way the data will be
coming in for years and years so there
will be lots of new things to study
discover and learn about what do you
think no that's a great idea Chris
anything to get us to stop talking about
Mars would be welcome even if it means
having to talk about Jupiter there are
lots of really fascinating things going
on past Mars I agree there's a there are
nice things about Mars it is a fairly
hospitable
place it went in terms of the rest of
the solar system like for Earth your yes
Earth is is definitely but you're not
gonna like it's very difficult to send a
probe to the surface of Venus where it
rains
sulfuric acid not a good place to hang
out and it's it's the hottest place in
the solar system you don't want to go
but mercury mercury is also in a
hospitable isn't it hotter than Venus
cuz it's closer to the solder on Venus
because of the greenhouse effect of
Venus because mercury doesn't have an
atmosphere and so it actually gets
hotter on on Venus think I don't like to
disagree with you when it comes to hard
science stuff but I read something on
the internet about how the greenhouse
the gas stuff that's not even true we're
gonna get back to Chris's question where
we look I'm not gonna okay it as John is
joking by the became visibly anxious
when I said that oh my goodness
we have a guest Oh a very special guest
oh hello
it's a wheezy waiter it's pulling up a
chair right now okay can we hear him
over there yeah you have to be on this
side yeah
so Craig benzine wheezywaiter has just
joined us we're talking about which
planets are the most fascinating which
planets are the most fascinating what's
in our solar system yes
okay what's your favorite planet in our
solar system let's all let's just turn
around and say you can't take Earth well
Saturn Saturn yep Mars you know if I
can't pick earth in a way there's seven
equally dead and meaningless rocks well
several of them aren't in fact rocks
don't they have Rock cores somewhere no
you're telling me that there are planets
that have no solidity just yes I did not
say that I said that they didn't have
Rock cores what do they have liquid or
solid hydrogen and helium is that Venus
wait so you're telling me there are
planets that are just liquid helium no
I'm saying that Jupiter and Saturn
Neptune had them are just gassy things
and so we're not sure what's the middle
because they're awful big but we think
that it's probably just really really
tightly compressed things that would be
gas if they weren't so tightly
compressed so you're telling me that I
couldn't stand on Jupiter it would be
like standing on a cloud no standing on
Jupiter would be like falling into a
cloud that became so dense that it
crushed you mmm doesn't sound like fun
don't do that once again earth the
number one place to live in the solar
system are you saying Saturn's like that
too
yeah yeah all the gas trance all right
no okay so in that case my favorite non
earth planet is gonna have to be the
moon it's close it's very close to Earth
which is great and then also it's
relatively hospitable because we had
astronauts on it but it's also not a
planet this is a thing that we could we
could play semantics and say you know by
the definition any definition all right
been my favorite and honor no actually
there are people who argue that the
Earth Moon system is actually a binary
planet system like two planets yeah the
earth is one in the moon as the other
yeah all right if the moon is a planet
I'm gonna pick the moon if the moon is
not a planet I'm gonna stun everyone and
pick Mars but only because the others
all the others are so useless like with
it with the with the wood the solar
system or any aspect of human experience
be in any way different if we eliminated
all seven of the other planets yes very
very different how tell me just the fact
that we would have had no planets in the
sky would have made it much more
difficult to figure out the how hot like
our place in the universe having those
other planets be these weird things that
were moving around that that was the
impetus for the Scientific Revolution
like that's how we figured out how
gravity works that's how Newton
determined am any of like many of the
things Newton's figured out really sure
an apple fell on his head and that's how
he discovered gravity I though I do love
your your question though how would
science have
have proceeded differently if we hadn't
have had these objects in the sky
behaving so strangely that would have
allowed it that allowed us to figure out
the rules of gravity and and motion
that's great um let's move on to another
question how long are you in your for
Craig well I'm leaving as soon as you
guys are done with me here okay so this
question is from oh right you're not
going to a plane do some try phone I can
drive but I do have I do have to be
somewhere this this this question is
from Stephen who asks dear John and Hank
and apparently Craig I've just turned
thirty as demonstrated that I listened
to your podcast and watch your videos
I'm still clinging to some semblance of
youth but my wife tells me it's all
downhill from here is she right first
off Stephen there's lots of adults who
watch our videos and listened to the
podcast thank you for being one of them
secondly I can report as a 37 year old
that in fact it's not all downhill
between 30 and 37 because I've found my
30s and I'm not just saying this because
I've had this like a strange good
fortune of professional success I found
my 30s to be an A+ number one decade if
I had to rank my personal decades
completely forget about strip away like
all all professional successes are
family there's just like relationships
and personal experiences relationship
with the world feeling of comfort and
satisfaction with the experience of
being alive I'm gonna rank them ready
okay 30s 10 to 20 20 to 30 zero to 10
zero to tens last because I didn't know
what the heck was going on I was just
like this is terrifying that was pretty
much until I was 10 years old I
essentially never had an emotion other
than fear that's I don't remember that
about you but I was very very young
you I sometimes like it's interesting
sitting here across from you because I
realize how much you talk you can just
go on Greg Greg rank your decades okay I
have to act
we agree pretty much exactly with with
Jen actually exactly I think I think my
thirties are my favorite because all of
the social anxiety that I felt in my 20s
and all of the uncertainty of like where
my life was headed is kind of gone and
not and not just because my career again
not just because my career is really as
I've had good fortune in my 30s but
because I feel more I guess I feel more
certain like are the things that used to
bother me don't bother me as much
anymore like like like if I you know say
something stupid in a conversation like
that whatever there'll be other
conversations like like stuff that you
that annoy you when you're younger I
think just kind of are glossed over when
you get over to me anyway it feels like
like I feel more comfortable in my own
skin I have so being a third person who
has experienced success in their 30s I'm
going to try and come up from a
different angle and say that I feel like
most of my friends are also that way
they feel like they've found more of
their place and more of what like they
feel comfortable with and like who they
are and it really I think like it's
strange and I'm interested to see what
my 40s are like because maybe it'll be
even better and I should ask some 48
year olds and be like hey how is the
40's going and see maybe it just keeps
getting better from like every until you
get to be the time when you're dying and
then it might be a little painful and I
fact I expect that the it'll be more of
like the 30s it'll just I'll just be
older that's what this 30s but older
until until you know until you tell I'm
going I mean I will have kids eventually
what which will change things quite a
bit yes there is a drastic drastic
drop-off in quality of life around 90
yeah yeah that sounds about right
I've never I've never spoken to someone
who said all right I'm gonna rank my
decades best my 90s they've been amazing
III just want to say that I find it
interesting that I forgotten his name
Stephen but Stephen has said that he's
trying to hope he's holding on to some
vestige of his you
which is which is evidenced by his
listening to our podcast are we a way
for people to hold on to their youths
are we just for young people John
I feel quite not young I feel like a 35
year old yeah they're a bunch of old men
you know what Ivan how you guys you mean
the three of us yeah you know what I've
just noticed thank what you can just
talk and talk about we got another
question
this one comes from Alex who writes Dear
John and Hank what clubs or sports did
you participate in high school and/or
college let's ask Craig as well you go
first
I'm from a very small town so I was able
there wasn't a lot to do other than
sports so I was able to participate in a
lot I participated in basketball
football and track well mainly were you
good at any of these I was pretty good
at basketball
yeah but then but then by a junior year
I wasn't tall compared to everyone else
no I I quit
oh so you didn't you didn't play in
college or anything no I did track all
the way up through senior year but of
high school but then but everything else
I didn't make it past junior year
yeah hey uh I played hockey in high
school a roller hockey right I remember
that and that was the only sport I have
ever played except for like Ultimate
Frisbee in college which was not
organized in any way it was a excuse to
it was a thing you could do wild
drinking beer yeah content of play
Ultimate Frisbee in drink beer at the
same time Caribbean sport not at a
professional level no yeah certainly not
and as far as clubs I was like in an art
club in high school I was in the AIDS
awareness Club in high school in college
I was in like an activism activist Club
that was sort of just angry about the
way that America treats the rest of the
world and also the institution of
capitalism sort of like that was that
was my main thing in college which isn't
interesting I've had an interesting
progression from that
yeah I wouldn't say you've completely
abandoned that no I said at your wedding
and I would stand by this that of all
the Communists I know Hank loves money
the most I I also would like to point
out that you were in the marching band
oh yes I was I didn't actually March
though because the the first year of
marching band I broke my foot and so I
was I was behind and so I was in the pit
I I played I played the pit percussion
mm-hm and I also was for a while the the
high school mascot Willie the Wildcat
that which is wonderful I mean I can
only imagine how good of a Willie the
Wildcat you must have been you're very
you know looking back I could have been
better I feel it's one of the things
that I regret that like I had this
opportunity and I was wearing and I but
like I was very self-conscious which is
strange because I was wearing a costume
no one knew it was me yeah it was very
self-conscious and I feel like I could
have been a better Willie what would you
have done differently I think I should
have been danced more I should have like
played with the children in the audience
in like and you know just been more
energetic and I mostly just walked
around and was like you know I'm also
surprised that you didn't dance more
because I happen to know that in 1998
you were voted best dancer by your
fellow students at Winter Park High
School but I never did it with a wildcat
costume on you only did it at prom no I
did it in the marching band like when we
were in the stands I would like totally
dance but when I was wearing the lulav
cat costume I felt self-conscious it's
very strange and I do not understand it
that is fascinating I was mostly an
ultimate frisbee player and I was I
would say ninth best out of out of the
11 starters and then I also I was very
involved in academic decathlon this
weird quasi sport where you participate
in 10 different academic events from
economics to speech to taking a history
test and you have to have each team has
to have 3a students with GPAs above 3.5
3 B students with GPAs between 3.0 and
3.5 and 3 C students and really of
course like you the difference between a
good Academic Decathlon team and a great
one is it C students because everyone
has smart a students and I was the C
student for our Academic Decathlon team
and in fact when
I was very close to getting a 3.0 GPA a
teacher who will remain anonymous but
who also worked with me on the Academic
Decathlon team said I can't help but
notice that you're doing quite well in
physics this year and I said yeah and he
said well I just want you to know we
don't have a spot for you as a B student
on the academic decathlon team so I
through physics you through it
I threw it I got a D in physics so that
I could maintain my C student status as
an academic athlete and thereby help my
school at the national tournament which
that year was in Newark New Jersey where
I very briefly but very intensely over
the course of about four hours while
drinking six wine coolers fell in love
with a young woman from Oklahoma who as
it turned out had a boyfriend but that
is a different story fascinating no idea
how corrupt yeah yeah I'm sure that that
has had I mean never mind this question
is from Calvin who asks dear Hank and
John do you think it's possible for
society to promote a good thing such as
a healthy diet or active lifestyle
without stigmatizing those who don't fit
that description
I think this is interesting particularly
from the public health standpoint of
cigarette smoking because a lot I feel
like a lot of the way that we
dramatically decreased the amount of
cigarette smoking in America was by sort
of having a negative image of people who
smoked cigarettes and I definitely like
Mike and I guess I still to some extent
have that where I'm like oh I'd you know
like oh you smoke cigarette I don't know
how to feel about that which is of
course you know it's well I think that
it's a little different like you mean I
grew up with the Maher I grew up smoking
cigarettes and I quit in 2002 and like
you know I grew up with the Marlboro Man
I'm like Joe cool the camel um who would
smoke cigarettes and magazine ads and
magazines I liked and everything but I
and I do think that like by shifting the
image
the smoker from a cool cowboy and or a
cartoon camel to you know people who
died of lung cancer in tuberculosis you
certainly I think that that resulted in
less smoking I think it's very different
than when you're talking about
obesity or or weight but it dies I don't
think stigmatizing obese people has has
in any which we've been doing right no i
centuries i don't think it's a decreased
obesity right definitely not I yeah I
think with smoking a difference is it's
obviously and always a choice to smoke
with OBC sometimes it's you know it's
genetic sometimes it's not controllable
so it's a little bit more of an if it's
also it's also not a very good reflector
of health like BMI the ratio between
your body weight and your height like is
not actually that Buddha predictor of
health outcomes like what what is
considered people people who live the
longest are actually people who are what
is considered to be overweight at least
in many countries so I don't I I think
it's like this whole idea that like
somehow stigmatize and fatness is going
to lead to a healthier country yes the
other thing is is feeling bad about
yourself does not tend to lead to less
poor decision rucking yeah i mean i bad
health like feeling bad about yourself
leads up to more bad health choices
right when I quit smoking I quit smoking
not because smokers were being
stigmatized I quit smoking because
people were telling me I could do it
right right and the other thing is that
it with smoking it is a thing that is
addictive and the goal is to not have
people start because once you start it
as difficult to stop mm-hmm whereas food
is something that all people need to be
eating I will say as far as an active
lifestyle goes that I do think that we
need to we should promote activity in
people who you know are able to be
physically active because that is at
least according to dr. Aaron Carroll
host of healthcare triage who was the
only person I know who is a health care
economist you know Aaron certainly feels
like exercise is the by far the biggest
thing that we can do for Public Health
today I will say personally I just
recently in the past like a year or two
started jogging a lot and exercising a
lot more and I feel way better than I
have like most of my life so you look
real good too
oh well thank you thanks I think that's
just mostly your eyes though well
beautiful I exercise my eyes so do it
tell me about your eye exercises well I
watch the vlog brothers we always pop
across the screen and obviously moving
from one side to the other a lot of jump
cuts going on there yeah on a giant
screen I watching on a wall projection
yeah every day zoom you lift eye weights
yes I do with fishhooks can't like very
sticky contact lenses you know after my
orbital cellulitis I did after you I
exercise yeah I couldn't see out of my
left eye for the longest time and they
were yes I did it was I don't it wasn't
muscle exercises but it was focusing
exercises where I would be like well I
guess they can't really see what I'm
doing right that's the death the
downside of the in-person podcast Hank
yeah is that I forget that are not
seeing what I'm seeing which by the way
what I'm seeing right now is Hank and
Craig Hank wearing a pink shirt Craig
wearing a PBS Digital Studios shirt
always reppin the brand and I just
realized now that Hank and I are wearing
nearly identical gray jeans correct okay
I think we got time for one last
question before we get to the news from
Mars and AFC Wimbledon this question is
from Johanna who asks Dear John and Hank
if you could have been a child prodigy
at any one thing what would it have been
oh can I keep that skill throughout life
I assume so that's how a child prodigy
usually works right
you don't forget how to play the piano
yeah because I feel like it would
probably be some kind of musical
instrument which one uh accordion are
there child prodigies in the accordion
maybe not yet yet who is Weird Al
Yankovic an accordion product you know I
doubt that
Yankovic could ever like he's a good
accordion player but I don't know how
but he is maybe he's very very good he's
just one of the only famous ones right
is it I mean and this is a genuine
question for the members of the dear
Hank and John community who are well
connected to the world of professional
accordions is is accordion something
where you would can achieve an acute
level of excellence or is it more about
like style you know I think it's
something you could achieve an acute
level of excellence at I mean you look
at the accordion it looks very
complicated it's got like 80,000 buttons
on one side I think that's an
exaggeration on the other side yeah I
think I think it's in the I think you
can have one with up to 92 or 108
buttons okay
and it's so that's a lot of buttons yeah
and if you want to be able to use all
those buttons I can't I can't imagine
how else what's going on in your brain
to even know where all those buttons are
and what they do sure so I think that uh
I think that I think you can continue
becoming a better accordion esteverena
the rest of your life if you wanted to
hmm Craig do I think that you can become
no what would what would your child
prodigy skill be I've been thinking
about it I guess either storytelling
like writing mmm writing I think there
aren't a ton of writing prodigies there
are some like Mary Shelley wrote
Frankenstein when she was 19
you know John Keats was a very good poet
by the time he was 17 or 18 but yeah I
mean it's not something that people tend
to be pretty
particularly precocious at when they're
kids yeah I think I was I liked it by
the English classes were my favorite
especially when the teacher had us write
short stories and I think I was pretty
good at making students the other
students laugh with my story yeah they
weren't they weren't keys right yeah
well I mean I recently reread one of my
stories from college thinking that I
could use it to Road you just as the
framework for writing a new book instead
of having to write a whole book which
seems like a lot of work and I remember
this story as being pretty close to
brilliant
and I reread it and I was like sadly
there is not even a salvageable
dependent clause in this entire 60 pages
so I certainly was no writing prodigy I
guess like if I could be prodigiously at
anything as a child it would have been
math because I find math to be such an
interesting language but it's also a
language that I feel like I speak or or
can use only only little bits of you
know like I like I speak math at a
five-year-old level but I'm fascinated
by the beauty of it and I think it would
help me to appreciate Mars better and
this sort of you know the the the vast
vast vast majority of the universe which
is outside of direct human experience I
feel like you know being able to speak
math helps you to interact with with
that universe as well as the human
universe a lot better and I regret like
not having a better sort of facility
with mathematics even in adulthood but
you know it is something that I've like
spent a lot of time trying to learn
about as an adult but I wish that I'd
just like picked it up when I was eight
I would have said math but I was not
proud of you at math oh right you did
yeah you already had that one Hank you
were kind of a math prodigy no no not at
all I remember you knew like you could
do your multiplication tables in like
third grade yeah sure that kind of math
but that's not the kind of math I want
to be prodigious at no you want to do
the leg calculus yeah interesting stuff
yeah the stuff like my friend Daniel
Biss does where you prove that a
triangle is really just a kind of circle
that's amazing it's mind-blowing more
like understanding why you know trees
have symmetrical leaves and stuff yeah I
don't know there's so much there's so
much beauty out there that you don't get
to appreciate if you aren't aware of
aware of it Hank yes speaking of beauty
that often goes unappreciated what is
the news from Mars this week do we want
to say goodbye to Craig first I probably
have to go
I really appreciate you guys having me
on this bucket yeah so thank you - Craig
wheezy waiter for joining us youtube.com
/ wheezy waiter also the host of the
good stuff youtube.com slash the good
stuff also the host of crash course
world government craft the crash course
regular government and politics on
youtube.com slash crash course regular
government mostly being American that's
yeah normal like like like American
cheese is thank you what kind of cheese
our global our global listeners have no
idea what American cheese is but let me
assure you friends you also don't want
to find out no it's only gonna
disappoint you Oh Craig thank you very
much for letting us thank you for having
me enjoy and go home to your to your
lady okay we're gonna hug it out thank
you all right Hank yes what is the news
from Mars this week this week in Mars
news
yeah John have you ever wanted to have
your name on the surface of Mars yes
because you can have that you really do
that right now
NASA is sending a mission to Mars soon
and included on that mission will be a
very small silicon chip then they will
be itching people's names into and I
just signed up where had them h my name
into this chip that they're gonna send
to Mars how much does it cost it's free
what it's free where can you go to sign
up you have to go to Mars nasa.gov go to
Mars NASA Govan you can have your name
etched onto a silicon chip that will be
on Mars will it stay on Mars yeah
forever yeah nope incorrect because in
forever the universe will just die okay
for at least a billion years yeah well I
mean unless Mars get gets hit by a
gigantic comet and that silicon chip
comes flying and hits earth and kills
somebody oh yeah then it would be on
earth in a person's head your name I
want to sign up for that yeah you can do
that it's totally free yeah it's
absolutely you're telling me
NASA is just giving away naming rights
to Mars no because AFC Wimbledon charges
a lot for them that's great
congratulations in AFC Wimbledon news
AFC Wimbledon just had an evening of
Paper Towns where the manager and
several of the players and lots and lots
of AFC Wimbledon fans decked out in
their AFC Wimbledon gear and went to a
theater in South London and all watched
the Paper Towns movie together and then
made me the sweetest most awesome video
about the experience which you can which
you can find on my Twitter twitter.com
slash John Green and it was really
wonderful
also Hank Callum Kennedy you know Callen
Kennedy AFC Wimbledon left back hero of
the AFC wimbledon wimbly want at least
the fictional version of AFC wimbledon i
play fifa with Calum kennedy scored a
goal against Cambridge United only three
points from three games so far worrisome
way but Callum Kennedy scored a goal for
against Cambridge and he did a
celebration that has gone viral in which
he attempted to recreate the
Velociraptor run from the movie Jurassic
world and if you have not had a chance
to see that you should because it is a
thing of true beauty that sounds that
sounds enjoyable to me John I have a
question there was one goal from Callum
Kennedy in this game I'm assuming that
it was not the only goal scored in that
game indeed it was not sadly there were
two goals scored by Cambridge hence
hence the zero points that came out of
that game so three league games so far
for AFC Wimbledon one win two losses
that means three points out of three
games not where we'd like to be but the
season is young hope is the thing with
feathers
what did we learn today Hank we learned
that John when he was sitting across
from you it really does hit home how
much he talks today's podcast is brought
to you by Hank Hank making fun of me for
talking too much even though I bet if we
did the math he talks [ __ ] dear Hank
and John than I do today's podcast is
brought to you by the person who is
actually going to do the math person
who's actually going to do the math you
are an amazing fan of this podcast and I
can't wait put it on Twitter today's
podcast is brought to you by your 30s
your 30s underrated the day the podcast
is brought to you by wheezy waiter we
also learned that both Hank and I played
Ultimate Frisbee as children yeah we
learned that John intentionally threw
his physics game so that he could
participate in another game I wouldn't
really call the study of physics in high
school in game you know your game though
you mean my grade yeah like your game
like this is Mike it's not like it's all
like it's a phrase like my physics game
is strong yeah okay I didn't know that
we were speaking so colloquially and of
course we also learned that Hank if he
just had the chance would have been a
brilliant young accordion estaphan but
that's what I want to have been and then
I couldn't bend man wouldn't it be
amazing with the perfect strangers like
I was like a rock and a QWERTY honest
but those of you don't know Hank in
addition to being a blog brother the
host of crash course the crew co-creator
of VidCon and dftba records is a rock
star and his band is called Hank green
and the perfect strangers and then
fortunately are not headed by a lead
singer who also plays the accordion
tragically Hank is unable to play the
accordion which is the reason that Hank
green and the perfect strangers will
always be a bit of a niche band really
holding us back
if only you could play the accordion you
guys would really break out on the
Billboard charts I think so you can
participate in dear Hank and John by
sending us questions to Hank and John at
gmail
calm this podcast is edited by Nicholas
Jenkins the theme music is by gunnarolla
and as they say in our hometown don't
forget to be awesome
[Music]